so we're going to talk about today
critical race theory
um so i'm going to set this up and i'm
going to i'm going to turn it to carly
to kind of break this down for us but
here's
what seems to be happening critical race
theory is all over the news both msnbc
box the left read me the right media
they're all covering it and
the narratives that are coming out are
not fun or easy to digest
essentially and this is gonna be the
layman's version we're gonna dive in but
the right
seems to be saying that critical race
theory is anti-american
and destroying america and the left
is saying that critical race theory is
essential and that those who don't
understand it or don't want to talk
about it
are unable to see the systemic
racism in this country um and it's a
very divisive
topic i actually push back on that i
think that the the narrative on the left
is that
we're not even critical race theory is
not actually what we're talking about
here and that the right is wrong
to be calling things critical race
theory either way
i feel like if you're the right you hate
it and if you're left
you're not allowed to criticize it
because if you do you're you feel like
you're a racist or
doing something um against what um
uh democrats are supposed to be fighting
for let's say and i think as usual the
truth is somewhere in the middle and one
of the things and i'll say this kind of
the first episode but as we do this i
don't want you to come to us
all the time for just like our opinions
what i want to do is kind of a breakdown
of the news and what
um you guys are adults make your own
decisions and based on um
the facts coming out of these narratives
or that are being ignored by these
narratives so
um so carly can you
help us understand maybe like basic
maybe start us with like the high level
definition of critical race theory and
then where these narratives are kind of
going
left right and sideways sure um i
actually think
and i will all kind of loosely define it
but i think that
the narrative that i see missing right
now in this conversation honestly or the
points that i see not being made
um is actually that the definition of
critical race theory is sort of besides
the point
um and i'll dive into that so broadly
speaking
critical race theory is a legal
framework
for looking at how our current systems
interact with race
you could say like a legal framework for
looking at systemic racism
and it's been taught it's academic it's
been taught in law schools for
decades and it's high level academics as
in like
you know for older people and and that
is important that becomes kind of very
central in the democratic narrative that
exists right now
so let's start where everyone seems to
agree
which is that all this talk about
critical race theory in the mainstream
seems to stem back to this one guy chris
ruffo
who's a conservative journalist
documentarian
who last year
became familiar with these anti-racism
trainings that were happening
within different federal agencies that
we're saying things like
you know meritocracy itself is white
supremacist
and values like individualism as white
supremacists
you know and then you know and then a
whole bunch of other things right around
systemic racism and privilege etc
and chris ruffo the narrative seems to
go
according to both sides is outraged by
what he's seeing here he goes on fox
news quite famously
and is on tucker carlson's show and
demands that president trump uh
ban critical race theory as part of the
trainings for federal
employees so trump does that biden comes
into office
and reverses trump's ban on critical
race theory and that's when the fight
really moves to the schools
and that's when chris ruffo starts
working with republicans around the
country
to write legislation banning critical
race theory
in schools in curriculums around the
country
and here's what's interesting so the
reaction that democrats
seem to have had to this whole thing
has been to take this line of
it's stupid to call this even critical
race theory this isn't
critical race theory critical race
theory is this high
you know level academic thing that is
taught in law schools
obviously we're not teaching that to
elementary school students and like
that's true but also to me feels like
it's very much missing the point because
it's not
like the point here is about the
curriculum and what we're teaching and
so
being like nana you're you've made this
intentional effort to make everything
bad critical race theory
it feels besides the point to me but
that seems to be what's being hammered
critical race theory was essentially
written by
two individuals in the 90s a couple
decades ago
derek bell and kimberly crenshaw in that
document if you're a republican
reading it um i don't think you would
agree
you would disagree as strongly as they
are right now if you actually read what
they wrote because they also
they talk about systemic racism on
things they also talk about
um material interest and structural
poverty and
um things that a lot of
uh a lot of us can agree upon like hey a
lot of our schools are not funded very
well like period
yeah right like there's things that they
are talking about that is bigger than
basically they're saying hey we should
be concerned with
the material well-being of minorities
and the way in which our legal systems
keep minorities from from material
well-being
rather than linguistic debates
right like if the point i think
summarized is like if we get every white
person
to stop ever saying or singing the n
word or whatever
you're still gonna have the wealth gap
and so like what really have we
accomplished
and i think there's you know that that
goes to i think something that speaks
that you and i agree with in terms of
not that we think people should be
saying the n word but that
like a universal basic income is such a
more powerful tool than
so many of the other debates we end up
having in the quote-unquote discourse
um because they even talk about
ncrt they actually get to talking about
solutions and policies as opposed to
just rhetoric and that
so it's it's the whole thing to me is
ironic we're like
we're debating or how terrible crt is
but no one's ever actually read
what they are and therefore we're not
actually debating critical race theory
we're debating
at its core what's getting taught to
children and then what we're allowed to
talk about and we should say this
critical race theory
is a is a body of scholarship so there's
not one thing this is why
you actually can't define it because
zach you're right that in some of the
early days in the early iterations of
critical race theory that's what was
being discussed but it
you've had other scholars weigh in and
other scholars focus on other things and
also that's true
it's a body do that under the umbrella
of critical race theory so this is why
you really
can't get to a definition of what this
is because it's a body of scholarship
with people saying
a whole bunch of different things about
what it is so my hopes of making this
simple for everybody
have been dashed and i think that's okay
because i think it doesn't
matter yes it doesn't matter okay keep
going okay so you have
a big blow-up that happens in loudoun
county in pennsylvania and this is what
you're hearing a lot about and if you're
seeing
um clips of parents like screaming and
being like
on either side of this but being like
how dare you teach my kid that because
they're black they're always
oppressed and because they're white
they're out they're inherently racist
that's probably from this loudoun county
school board
meeting or meet series of meetings that
have happened because of some proposed
changes to the loudoun county
curriculum so the daily covers this as
part of their
coverage in general the daily podcast
covers this as part of their general
coverage on
like what is critical race theory and
what i found so striking
was they keep it
the whole episode kept it sort of very
high level and they didn't at any point
get into the specifics of what the
proposed curriculum was
is in loudoun county which feels to me
like
what we actually should be talking about
not like what is the definition of
critical race theory so
i want to just the conclusion that
is formed in this daily episode is that
basically the fight over critical race
theory is a fight between two camps
the first camp that's call it in favor
of critical race theory though those are
the same people who are being like
this isn't actually critical race theory
republicans are creating a straw man
boogeyman to attack and it's not even
what this is like they're so stupid
right that same camp um
are the people who are willing to admit
that systemic racism exists and
that it's something we need to tackle
and something we need to teach our kids
and that for too long our education
system has completely
has treated racism like it's something
in the past and we need to fix that et
cetera et cetera
so the daily is saying that's the people
who are in one camp of this and the
people on the other camp of this
are and the way they do it it feels very
much like are the people who are
unwilling to acknowledge systemic racism
and are unwilling to grapple with
the idea that america isn't the perfect
bastion of meritocracy that they once
thought and that they themselves may be
a part of a problem
they really paint it like people who are
kind of unwilling to face
and the feeling you get is like the
reality about america
and i can give you the exact quote yeah
can you give it a quote is is michael
barbara who's the host of the daily
says so at its core this is about
and that this is the fight over critical
race theory
so at its core this is about whether a
large group of americans mostly white
but not all white
can or should accept the idea that
racism is not merely historical
not simply a relic but something very
present and systemic and something they
need to take responsibility for
and then the guest responds yes that's
right so they've summarized this as
being this is a fight about
whether or not people will take
responsibility for systemic racism what
is frustrating to me when you hear that
is that
i'm of the camp where and i think a lot
about
i would argue that the majority of
americans are in this camp where like
systemic racism exists we have
structural problems in this country
um that are advantaging certain races
ranging white races over over black race
like you go down the list at the same
time
you can still think that teaching a
child that competition and meritocracy
is inherently racist um is a bad thing i
think those are things that made america
fantastic um and
yeah i agree daley's arguing that we
can't talk about it without
like if i take the other side of that
that i'm racist
and i'm not acknowledging there's no
systemic racism
this is the needle that needs to be
thread right and this is
you have and this is what i'll end up
repeating this over and over again i
feel like as we have these conversations
because i think it's what you see
very consistently which is you have
repo you have democrats focusing on a
macro narrative
you have them saying systemic racism
exists
we should be teaching this and then you
have republicans focusing
on a micro narrative which is okay well
third graders in cupertino
were asked to rank themselves and their
classmates according to their privilege
which you know it just means according
to like race features which is
bizarre and reductive and doesn't take
into account all sorts of other
dynamics and a fan like all these other
things that can make somebody privileged
or not and it's also just a really weird
way to start training third graders to
think to think in my opinion
and as somebody who very much believes
in systemic racism so you have
republicans focusing on these like micro
examples of things in curriculum that
feel to a lot of us
as being quite off and and so you have
these two groups talking past each other
because we're not arguing about the same
things
and and it's so frustrating to me that
the new york the new york times
in this daily episode and i take the new
york times because again they're held up
as still like the gold standard of
journalism in a lot of camps
so you know you know you're getting that
narrative or worse in the other
you know mainstream media channels right
like the new york times was
taking the stupidest of the rights
arguments
and debunking those in this podcast
instead of taking
frankly the most legitimate of the
rights arguments and debunking those
and this is what you see over and over
and over again which is so freaking
frustrating so
i would say like the needle to thread
here is
is to me there's a lot yes
systemic racism exists clearly there are
all sorts of systems and you can
i could talk to you about them there's
this there's a whatever we don't have to
get into that if somebody
doubts this feel free and i can debate
it with you um
right there there are legal systems that
have existed and frankly continue to
exist
that very much clearly disadvantage
like black people other races other than
white people
at the same time to treat it like
you are racist because or like you don't
believe in systemic racism
because you do have problems with some
of the specific things being taught in
these anti-racism trainings
and and have a problem with everything
being reduced
to power according to race which
which is absolutely happening um
it's it's ridiculous
you